these are the kind of comments you did
once of full podcast welcome to the
what's on full podcast we got Johnny
Rock over here looking up EOW from
Venezuela
well three guitarists co-host of the
year it's happening yeah five year
running yeah nobody can bring them down
not even hooter we got Lisa Esparza here
way to orange shirt just came back from
pitching show April Macie from the hot
new show on Netflix yeah you ready ready
yeah because we have a we have a
convenient Willie Barcena and he will
talk immediately they [ __ ] up or they
were not funny bro you weren't ready
dogs like I brought you too soon like it
like he would take an opener like a guy
named Archie Moreno from the yoyoyo
podcast that guy was that guy what well
you know like he was like you know I
don't know if you ever work with
comedians or you been just a headliner
and you know what the headliner tells
you bro you know that joke you do about
parachutes don't do that and when you
refer to your girlfriend Maria change it
say Nancy could I say Maria also brought
tornadoes out the new tornado Joe's
broken when I grew up bro I make a
reference about tornadoes in the Midwest
and always a beer so there's any beer or
Elvis references to you know cuz I think
like I started
headlining pretty fast after last comics
yeah like I got 30 minutes and I was
doing like weird math sheds no des told
me [ __ ] you little bro sold out tonight
five minutes so then I started
I started riffing with a crowd you know
trying to cry man so what do you do for
a living really what do you work at
who's your boss
so then after another night he's the
same comedian told me a bro don't talk
to the audience he's away from me
talking to the audience so now live with
two minutes so I'm bobbing all week now
so it didn't a week the the guy is drunk
he looks at me man you know what man
you're not ready but it's not your fault
not your fault
I saw you bro and I thought you were
ready it's my fault bro I brought you
here too soon oh yeah that's so that's
why we used with a short car they ready
oh I think about it you're not ready by
the time you get anything in
entertainment it's already five years
past the point where you felt like you
deserved it and you're like of course I
fractured well April Mason that we we
should do a show and also um I mean Joe
Diaz did it once too and it was called
the wild wild west comedy club in Odessa
oh that guy is now serving two
consecutive life sentences for one else
yes yes Big Mike and David took wasn't
them the bartender the wait the bar John
robic John Romans one of the only people
that's ever ripped me off in my whole
comedy career
they rip you up did he give you a check
that was it next year well you know when
you say somebody oh yeah well then it
was but he give you a bunch of cash that
you could have called that what all that
was because you're too buzzy later you
know when you see somebody like writing
a check and they're like nervously
smoking while there's writing like oh no
I just like shaking a return check
that's right you performed in December
was dated four weeks later January -
yeah because we called the lawyers and
we got a newer check sent to us we call
it I got only the agents on that one cuz
that's some shady [ __ ] cuz he handed it
to you you didn't notice he also didn't
they also didn't pick you up for the
airport the next day I think on that gig
right like you're stranded like nobody
woke up to pick you up cause what
happened oh that my first time there um
we're just driving and they look at me I
think Big Mike says um it mean you want
to go to God we're gonna go to a fight -
in one of the fights you know all happy
and I said I don't know man it's pretty
early for a fight right yeah yeah but
dogfights
man I got like $4,000 on this dog man
dog fight though I'm out bro and then he
was there hanging out with some biker
guy who drove a motorcycle and then
there's another guy who was like the
ecstasy doctor like I'm like if you're
on ecstasy hope guide you through your
whole level shaman the Med when you go
in you're like oh no this is you start
rethinking your career choices really
like this is no place for a lady
no funny man the guy that was driving to
the airport and when I got through the
airport I was smoking weed all the way
there and then I got then I gave him
everything I had man after when I left
here bro you could have he was all happy
commander yeah and then uh when it
really like when I got through they have
both the flight for the next day don't
forgot I had to come back the same guy
pick me up bro and every sit with
pockets hilarious that car they told me
that they told me that the screens you
don't want to get it why do it was like
Johnny's car oh that the screech screech
screech Dustin that I'm his brother
he got picked up in our old beat out of
you got picked up in that real fancy old
be the red Cadillac and the you know how
the the upholstery is coming down so it
looks like are unglued
it looks like one of those fancy beds
should be a lady in there so you know
what I go in at those ceilings have like
push pins on the top you're seeing when
they push it back up and there's like
the thumbtack I think every car that my
parents own there's a photo from
everyone sure I did there and everybody
wearing my frilly base as far as a
t-shirt that the old one eight to have
which one and we're all holiness we're
all holding assault rifles everybody
went that pretty sure went to prison
ever except me
I didn't know that they live in the
place to Iran it to her what so many
airport you were happy a lot buoyed by
what the president yeah that's out there
all the time like I never know how they
paid me there was like four dudes and
dirty t-shirts and like drinking buckets
a but I'm like cash and run but they
were laundering money through that place
I have no idea because even job dear
Sarah's damn bro those nine people and
every sure this kept baby on it was out
of a job
but it was tip jar key water is water
just people know I'd go to that meth
shed twice a year
- that's like we're family now there was
math not coke oh no I don't know what no
I don't know there was man any meth
coming out of that barn because I didn't
see any math you know yeah blood well
you're not doing drugs
it's harder no well you know this when
it's happening but if you're like you
say I was involved doing drugs and that
guy off that comedian Stephen fly
perform there and he said that when he
was there somebody I she was doing jokes
about white people and then I in between
the Act one of the white people inside
put on his KKK hood could I have met
that I met I met that I met the ladies
that I met that guy's wife her name was
Connie on or name was but that person
who to put under hood I know here myself
too
you know he said he's an ecstasy of
shaman mr. bite he's like this dude bro
that looks like Hulk Hogan bro if you
wouldn't want to wrestle bro but just
beat up people and chicken wire bro like
he looked like no not someone that was
over there
yeah but that dude was cool bro that
full showed up from nowhere and he go
you just saw your t-shirts and I stole
like 10 I only have left over like 20 or
I'll buy oh ma I'm really excited on for
10 bucks right here 200 bucks right
there a Basso t-shirt that would
everybody got a rifle and it really
opened her - bro he was he was in Adam
Murray brought cheerleader bro - what he
would ask nobody was even looking at the
opener bro right
I used to hold it father watch it he was
carrying this box was afraid of put it
anywhere
anyway I'm verse 2 how many shoes you
have it display by like for all kindness
Adam Murray movie after two he tries the
convenience to do radio prayers in
Orlando Florida that's their problem
well that guy bro yeah creep down Sandra
Bullock well that was like without the
order asked me you wanna sign your name
on nerve you know that little favorite
wall whatever walk yeah that's all right
I said yes they like the chameleon Adam
very good Hey yeah and I said well oh
how wonderful they don't have no one for
a [ __ ] yeah now for openers yeah I
stopped my friend even when I put it
over there continue this is unbelievable
I guess you raise different like some
kami you don't know that you know you
learn this you know it's so hard it's
hard to learn in on the road man just
hurt so much to watch it happen yeah
like just because I just say I want to
go work somewhere with Russell Peters
right or somebody was cash somebody
could pay you well
Tiffany Haddish dollars Shiva damage now
you know and you know whatever right I
know now that they only care about
Russell Peters or Gabriel esters or
whoever and I'm there you know opening
yeah but I didn't know that when you
come back they're not there that you do
like [ __ ] dog
especially you don't bring in the same
numbers so I don't Marie said that uh
that that guy from was the name dope is
Oh Frank del Pisa Frank Pepe's a booking
for a show and Darren Carter was there
and they were like no green room you
know that Hornblower's and then when he
got there he was like first of all here
after the show hey is there a room you
go nah is it a Felipe show straight up
told you we only booked we only get roof
of the headliner so we're gonna dance
your [ __ ] car no no that would have
cleaning it out sleep on my shirt [ __ ]
so yeah man so what's up April Macie oh
not much I just got back yesterday from
Florence Italy damn
yeah my husband lives there what's that
where did you get married was that
Sardinia no it was a Santorini Greece
country
oh the economy shitty so you can get
like a dude to blow up by his hands on a
barge and have fireworks for like 400
bucks it's really nice a shitty economy
so it's it's much cheaper your values
your dollar value much better when the
crisis another everything went to [ __ ]
down Greece was like the last country
was like you know like you know just the
other when you drop all the dominoes
Greece was one of the last dominoes and
data in their whole I think they're more
vulnerable yeah somebody has to pay
these debts oh yeah but it's stunning
so these cheap everything's pretty cheap
yeah yeah yeah get a nice chicken juror
live like a king for $10,000 a year you
can
you can go break some like most of
Europe you can live much much much the
cost of living is like a sixth of what
it is here do them like nice summers
don't I mean human transportation is
easier and I'm here like four days a
month and I sold my car I live over
there you can just you didn't get
somewhere for like I got a ticket to
Krakow Poland for 11 euros
round-trip like you can't get a bus here
and uber uber brought over yesterday and
the guy had just been cleaning his car I
told him why he showed up to the house
and I'm trying to find my sunglasses so
I could just put on my headphones and
but today I fell asleep and ignore him
yep so his car smell like detergent fool
let there like not lemony no man I think
that the journey of my our mom's use
brilliant yeah the powder he dropped a
whole box of that blue liquid
you gotta get naked cello so bro no
those who believe sorry told ya sorry
thorn the powder one Oh
so what everyone saw a tone and the
liquidus why I tell ya like like my mom
put too much detergent on my clothes and
was too cheap to use the hot water so it
is more like tied so hey one of those
cheap people you know with ACS so I said
I'd lower my window each other the a/c
bro my way to reach over Bush Fraggle
here
do you want me to report you to Luba
right that's what I do when you roll
down the window I turn on the AC oh but
I mean it yeah it doesn't make sense to
have it on like though you said never
has the AC arm roll like it's like a
baby why cuz like I never had it growing
up but like I like to spoil yeah dude I
blast it but I mean there's no reason to
have an honor
I never had it growing up there [ __ ] we
never had heat I saw old poverty so I
want to throw back photos of you in a
swimming pool
Oh
like vacation right here my dad's
lighting a cigarette and you can tell
like I probably got a beat down before
it's feeling like a real level of
concentration and and focused no
remission dreams at that age that's
there was a lot of coke parties like I
probably went to have more coke parties
when I was second tire adult life
everywhere all those dealers were doing
it for big-headed [ __ ] yeah better so
their last job was done in toward steel
sacks
yeah when I what do we did the last
comments down into it we wouldn't do
Allentown Englewood or the corner no you
know your towns a dumb place in Illinois
I think like with you I didn't tell him
or Evanston ever said yeah I feel like
you know your towns kind of a dump every
daily Joel singing about it about the
best of America
factory whistle opening up visit our
hero Larry Holmes proud I got away I
thought she was looking like bag bigger
joke two or three students at that one
thing that Muhammad Ali said you know I
wish I had a town I could call my own
like the way that uh that billboard
didn't go down home of Larry Holmes yeah
I want my billboard in my hometown same
tone like hobos you still the one that
has that you Jersey there's a bridge
yeah yeah you cross right over there you
could buy alcohol I think in nineteen in
Jersey
I know that was kind of diverse you know
about you sitting there and I saw three
to two little white kids and some guys
who look like a Puerto Rican Latino kid
we all had [ __ ] do they have mother's
dog well that's our town people are
still rocking and sit up we go man like
I'm still thinking like foods like
trailer trash bro I was a man I guess
these these are the next
Intercontinental title they look just
like the boxcar that's a good stripper
name area like it enough DC there a
stripper what's the name of it and it's
been around since the eighteen hundred
reams but dreams El Paso know that was
enough DC and they serve steak the only
particular steak ever lap dance
that's very strange Commonwealth the
Commonwealth no but I had a good name
that matches that area
Bob's gone yeah Kelowna meme the
Cavanaugh's that's a true gentleman so
that's a lot my house it's um looks like
a strip competition in Philly alone
maybe like five or six years ago and the
women like one came down on a zip line
one turn or something like a human
sundae they were was impressive the cash
was pretty good they make as much as
those broads I think the prize was like
30 or 40 grand it was hosted by some
alcohol company and then they got a
comedian to do whatever a year and
nobody cared about my my subtle
introductions nobody they really kept
this broad off the stage let me say
Holloway's it's your juice not only play
somebody told you right now when I
looked it up and like they really serve
steaks and prime rib and all that but
they have strippers yeah it's a place
for lady what a meal do you feel like
you would wanna maybe I will take the
lap down first because I want to get the
lab that are foolish that sound like a
British guy man you're eating harder
potato like the proper chap I'm watching
that show turn and oddly the Redcoats
were a [ __ ] party hard and I never
seen like people party late in the
colonial days they were party dirty yeah
first of all they were they were party
but everybody had their own bucket to
throw up Oh keep the party grow up and
peace although
throw up and then like a little kiss
that an American will or a slave will
grab it throw the trash come back and
with the empty one and they don't just
talk anymore [ __ ] up and then I'm a
after that I'm a bunch of our hooker
American hookers show up and we're
talking about he's gonna throw up ten
times you know they brush their teeth so
now they're making all the diseases that
we have right now
so there are tearing everything up is
mayhem bro let's do some dues too they
showing it you know everybody is so Hulk
this is the weird one they cleaned up
but they're still [ __ ] up and they
start dancing blood I won't and then
they sit down and have a nice dinner
really nothing happened that's how you
do it huh but we're talking about they
were planning out how to kill Washington
and how to beat America but man the man
he talked about partying broke but
damages that is throwing a bucket of
throw up but you could show an HBO was
about a strip club in Philadelphia and
then all that I was watching it I saw my
math teacher and he had like a dollar
bill in his face when you see a teacher
in other places
ah like I stopped my teaching myself
grocery shopping at they are yes I have
that all he's poor that was that I've
got a bill that's all week week child
support
[Laughter]
that all my homework where's my mama
tell me that's what wrinkled it up or
drop Lord on the corner Crisco but that
biggie saw the lobby I don't know people
eat like the chorizo days I'm out make
sure you saw an eggs tacos or whatever
but then let the oil be leaking oil
it'll leak from your are and don't
engage sometime I erased my answer were
erased bro I will try to keep my
homework real nice and neat now fold it
then when I saw my teacher here look I
could use it as a [ __ ] to eat over it
now again some teachers care some people
yeah my son's a teacher she lost
assignments cuz she's like shoved them
in the backseat of her car and so she
lost them because I was like he turned
these you know it's possible that I
could have lost I did have some in my
bag so she like gave everybody you know
credit for it yeah I was so mad like you
just were about to give him a failing
grade for not turning this in but when I
step in and say I know he did this
homework like I was a checked it and I
was like it was lost in my backseat
it was whittling a pencil with a knife
however like I have no pants so I had a
pencil sharpener bro and had order do it
and we're biting a dog my dad would
sharpen ours with knives some people
would have it done but you can tell some
people has a construction worker yeah
the back of the class would be so sharp
they had that extra piece you just flick
off yeah the sharpest I remember
somebody hit a [ __ ] substitute with
the [ __ ] sharpest pencil because as
I'm out of here
I had a bus driver give up
those were a bunch of [ __ ] that would
look like the dad and family matters and
that was it yeah he grabbed his lunch
bro and it's thought you took a CB radio
out it was still it
he waited out there and I guess then I
guess I told about you bet just get back
in that bus so there's no way that I
replace you
so you were back here illegals no you
better have a different attitude
everybody was all quiet various your
parents had a sign oh yes I know
everything like third look whatever
grade you don't know curse I find I
remember I tried to sign my mom's name
and pencil like four hundred erase marks
I don't my teacher my mom didn't know
how to write her own name
[Laughter]
because my mom always let we wrote our
own notes and we sign her name all right
sighing her name
I wrote everybody's excuse notes my mom
you know I told you I did her taxes all
that stuff oh really
what age 14 there's but signing the
excuse note that was to happen years ago
years before that yeah that's [ __ ]
crazy dude my mom doesn't know how to
write her own name I remember I'm
plugging the phones in the morning
because they're gonna call and I hugged
a boy my teacher and eighth grade you
love eh bro history teacher class and
then like and she's you didn't not do
your homework
so jump up paper that stays in your
homework and give them your assignments
and she'll put it right there in front
of you you gonna sign in your ass you're
gonna sign in and she'll fold it up and
I'll show men at your house you don't
forget it yeah well I do it if you
waited as J before that male dog but I
forget mailman right there
I got away for a while for chair
touching the memory before you get to
our house yeah anything go to our house
I remember they used to pin a note to it
like a shirt and [ __ ] like we're like
first or second grade they would do that
think about it you don't have you're not
a liar you're not even like conniving
enough to take that little note yeah
yeah
I remember you you think the world was
gonna end at they [ __ ] we're gonna
call your mom my dad so big Stan and
remember we always come in with because
I was allowed to talk to boys so if
there was any boys on the horizon he'd
come into like a football game and it's
sweatpants always be falling down his
[ __ ] it's humiliating me
no boys if they called he but it's a boy
terminate the phone call no I wasn't on
say my legs I know though man so I'm
starts jumping on you it's over
no dangly earrings and I'm like trying
to wipe it off didn't he wear or have
extra clothes that they would take to
school like I hope they stole and then
they like the fashionable stuff that
they stole yeah I was always sneaking
some horror gear to speak up at the bus
here cuz my parents were married and she
was pregnant young so they were like you
will not make the same mistake yes never
Preakness [ __ ] cycle and I was like
no boys I'm like all the water boys like
if you told somebody no Tangerines
they'd be rubbing tangerines
sneaking him boys to my canopy I had a
canopy beds making a man room I did I
would say I was too scared to sneak out
but I would sneak him in and then you
know he'd make out on my canopy well my
porcelain dolls watch
Julia busted um the one time my dad
heard a noise it was the middle of
winter and my window was open and then
he went out with my dog Pookie looking
for my my high school boyfriend way to
throw back out there in the snow
ya know but never he took the door off
my my bedroom off the hinges and then I
was not allowed to have a door for a
year quiet whoring keep you from having
sex like going all the way no you know
they were more lenient like I would have
been a normal person wouldn't be think
because it was so prohibited I was like
that's all I walk I need at all yeah
give me the jacks there's only one deck
it was really one you know he was
motivated he would sneak out of his
window like shimmy down a tree push his
rabbit down the driveway like come over
in my house it was like a whole
situation yeah my girlfriend would come
over I'd have a garage house ah
so like she'd come over like I turn in
the morning a good either like be
fighting I know I gonna have makeup sex
and then like what would you Bruce some
order to fight all the fight is not over
say oh you are this is when you're in
your religious household yeah yeah yeah
oh I'd like 16 17 yeah yeah but I said
like I said I've been sexy on go yeah I
got 15 yeah good times oh yeah yeah
you do yeah they still took us like the
Planned Parenthood like me and my
girlfriend to Planned Parenthood
together like we're gonna do this anyone
have a baby [ __ ] like classes first
before he got bad health class in like
ninth grade and like a lot of people in
my like school district got pregnant I
think we were like number one mountain
do high school I was a peer educator so
we would go around as high school
students to our fellow high school
students and like try to dispel myths
that you can't get pregnant the first
time and can't get pregnant if you do
continuation yeah which allowed girls to
it without bacon but we didn't have a
school for pregnant chicks yeah we have
to take care of our school but I
remember like I remember being at the
Glendale Galleria and also who came in
that was from a pregnancy school and
there's girl were young full like 14 12
13 they were operating I've never seen
anybody pregnant that young many bikes
covered will prove that you're 17 or 16
when she had more than April May I
almost had sex really young and then we
were my friend Wendy written houses
backyard 14 brothers and sisters kind of
loud it was free range you want it was
camp in Iraq yards a lot it was an
aggressive
we were gonna have sex I was a Cody have
a condom and he said no but if I go back
home my mom won't let me back we can't
do it then and that's what I almost like
to say I had sex early and by early I
mean after it happened I went home and
watched Fraggle Rock did you wear any
with your other girlfriends no yes for
good
did you a condom all the time who sold
you the cotton at the liquor store you
just go I want condoms they don't get
money from I had like a I don't leave
the jobs I don't take my quarters I was
there for my kids I probably stop giving
them allowing once they had a girlfriend
oh yeah was there a girlfriend I would
like dope but like I'd go to work with
my dad I'm like I hear that like like
jobs fully sporting cheer the church
doing the Lord order a chair through the
tidings I was a lot of baby sit before I
was allowed to stay home alone by myself
which never made to be responsible for
other people's children their parents
didn't want you near their stuff
probably good stuff nice to read my
mom's likes what they were like Harold
Robbins novels like bloody things
write them down and put the boy's name
that I liked a lot of heaving breasts
shock in my notebooks at my house I
babysat at the parents the dad had those
little like this panel like the Spanish
little books in English but little sex
cartoon books yeah and I would look
through those be quiet well supposed to
be babysitting that's 15 I found a
bestiary book one of those text books
you know like people like I don't know
just people talk about bestiality book
growth all written you know what I like
to read
oh [ __ ] and I was like Freud I should
read the stuff our work found it and it
was all like a woman with a dog yeah
[Music]
what is this anyway they're at the
airport like you can get them right
they're everywhere yeah it's a lady
thing I think it's like it's all very
rivalled and like romantic it's not
really downright dirty right who's that
like what's that movie that just came
out a couple years ago yeah even that is
not even that's pretty tame compared to
on that hold me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
like how the Big Mike actually came out
better
what is dancing oh my god his favorite
porn that she was talking about to
Mike's apartment yeah Mike's popular
he's talking about a viral video but
it's the same thing I think is the same
thing same genre of Michael apartment
this is dancing bear and it's it's like
a fake totally fake bachelorette party
guys dancing and a bear bear mask and he
just butt naked people are in
everybody's like walking everybody late
he's going around like anonymous sex
yeah down there are y'all taking turns
going down in here but not everybody cuz
you're gonna make it a little late yeah
one yes I do but it's real though that's
the with a bear and what does anonymous
hurries Hollywood Christmas Hollywood
out how do we parade and like do it
walking bro get the black bikini and hit
the [ __ ] bear bass the ocean a
dancing bear I want ice cream
I'm the only one recognizing what's his
body good the bear head okay I guess in
shape daddy bear it's like you think
those those casting couch no the one
that already pull over in the van the
banging brothers van yeah
I notice well not just that it's they
also have to be tested before it you
know they're not gonna pull a random guy
off the street and have sex but red-nose
a funny how guys think of that movie
differently than girls I think what when
you talk about that roller the roller
girl thing and her pulling over how he
said like that's a thrill for a guy but
for girl you see the sad the preamp you
have empathy for compassion for human
life
the guy with an [ __ ] in high school
like that's just probably well this is
that part the point of talking about an
example because but up until then nobody
was doing what Burt Reynolds did in that
movie was pick up a random stranger have
sex with him because that was like that
was like that was like they John said
they knew in the beginning I was gonna
the future reporting it is the future of
porn bangbus worldly but he couldn't see
the people still thought so I'll go
ahead
no it's gonna say didn't they used to
like big directors with when it was film
they would most of them would start and
porn
that's huge just work on lighting angles
no it's really drilled down to just
pornhub where you just find a 10 second
clip or whatever it is you need and
you're just shopping for a quick fix now
movie trailer does the sea and all sex
happening now is just two guys that goes
a was swap daughters yeah is really
confusing and I know they're not but
sometimes they have like ah with we're
they
or the creepy dad shows up with a hot
daughter with this and then he has his
creepy ass friend - of the hot daughter
and they [ __ ] your switch bro they swap
it's very all the lines have been done
we ate nut clacking bro there's debrie
good people like endless rap game though
watching a nice apartment dancing bear
what some bloopers there's one way Kevin
like a gangbanger guess again what do
you think one good one do didn't get his
turn or whatever body bro
it's a fight Ashima talk about battered
the slap each other like lifesaver with
a penis but they start fighting bro over
that [ __ ] yeah another one like the guy
passed
that's this guy far in the girls face
parting is a directors the regular you
going we're not done with the scene and
the cameraman has to be the worst
because man he's like Vietnam yeah
that's a tough gig Brotherhood in here
you have to hold everything then they
cut you know they're wiping himself yeah
the smells
yeah
me suggesting they coming to you know I
said listed that doesn't mean their body
is clean initiative in that room don't
know where the place Mel Ron Jeremy's
but what Roger my female comics friend
friends I guess he shared like a road
manager with some other person than she
was friends with this road
do you want do you want to go up for
drinks with Ron Jeremy and I'm like no
but I want him to come over my house and
play cranium so I can get pictures for
face okay well we're need all my holiday
chocolates meeting blueberries here in
LA and then I moved to New York after
about two and a half years and then came
back to LA in the first place from I had
no life skills and my I was a troubled
child my parents were worried about me
and then I had my three cousins all on
Network series at the same time she was
like pushy stage mom and then I was a
nanny for my cousin who was on the nanny
I really had nothing else going on in my
life and then I found comedy found
comedy after my I was engaged at the
time and my ex had a restraining order
because I slapped him when he was
[ __ ] home with a restraining order
gonna go gonna go and that's how I
started comedy after a restraining order
for slapping a man on a friend's couch
action
[Laughter]
you don't have time to process you don't
know that you just got slapped what a
[ __ ] for calling the cops
no he was an [ __ ] and the funny thing
is like years later he was like what I
never told you was I've never dated a
woman who hasn't hit me you're like oh
man every woman he was infuriating way
more stable than I was way more stable
making better choices like the cipher
that was of the breath the bad breakup
or hot super him oh well I didn't know
that he was gonna come home with a
restraining order like I thought we were
going rollerblading I thought we made up
and I was like hey do you want to go
rollerblading and he was like yeah when
you just keep your skates by the door
so I rollerblade it right out of his
lies you on the house turn hot seat
contest yeah funny hot chick country
we're actually we're listening to the
Howard Stern when you were on oh yeah
you Whitney and Esther Esther yeah yeah
here's go to interview yeah first with
the help you career I would say so like
I started I mean it gave me a career on
the road I wasn't working at Hooters
ya know but I did it helped it I mean
what else can I do is there like five
people mention my face that was like a
rant brands a beast no so you're you're
married no matter it is we got married
one September second a year ago so we're
really making it guys I feel like one
year in each other how many times I go
back to Italy once a month so like into
your home how many none none my
husband's Iranian so we're dealing with
travel BAM okay
so now it is it's it's kind of crazy
like you just can't believe just because
he's irani just because he's not man but
he doesn't mean he doesn't live
no he's lived in Italy since he was 17
so his entire adult life has been
wearing skinny jeans like he's the only
guy I've ever dated that has like his
own taste in clothes where you don't
dress them up normally you get a dude
you're like your style is my style then
they go out of the house like this
cardigan yeah yeah they're wearing
featherweight cashmere and they don't
know why but he has his own specific
taste it's very strange wears like I
only wear raw edge shirts we have
another in Florence I hadn't dated in
like two years my friends like you're
starting to get weird like I just gave
up because my ex was a comedian and then
he broke both his feet and after we were
broken up he came back to live with me
because he needed surgery so I ended up
taking care of him like a year after we
were broken up for like 7 months I got a
link when you have two broken feet like
you can't even get juice so I'm like
just getting this new juice all the time
and then I just had it like I tapped out
of dudes just I'm done with dudes for a
while I've been in this dude game a long
time he's not going you jumped up
something that was 12 feet high you
thought he was an athlete but he had the
body of a licorice yeah so my husband's
just a nice human being and I kept going
back and now we have a nice home in
Florence you try to squat out one kid
with these 17 eggs I got left I know
I've been watching 90-day fiance
those women is 53 oh he's got one egg
shake it out somebody social media put a
picture up of it and it was it gonna
have a cigarette coming out I call
Geraldo a few years old so yeah so what
happens with the travel ban then is
there any hope for you or well we have
another interview because I wrote a
letter because like yeah we had our one
year anniversary and I'm like my
husband's never been in my home and this
is [ __ ] crazy and so I wrote this
letter and we got another interview in
October so when I go back October 22nd
so we'll see I can't imagine them
bringing us back down to Naples Italy
and then denying us again cuz you had to
file this waiver so you go through the
initial immigrant like anyway it says or
you just go through the normal process I
think it's process is in certifying in
six years to thousands and thousands and
thousands of dollars in immigration
attorneys and yeah like I think we're in
for like 14 and just four emigrate like
the first round of immigration papers
and then so we filed it it was like a
year we had our interview and then
because of the presidential proclamation
they just hand you new fathers waiver
which was a hundred and twenty seven
pages they wanted every place he had
traveled in the last 15 years who paid
for it like how would you remit I can't
remember where I was two weeks ago
because if you mess up on one man you
know a million dollars that you let you
in for the travel ban I'm like how do
like his mom what's denied a visa like
his sister's a citizen it's a county
deny a 67 year old woman or as a house
coat and makes hot lemon water in the
morning like what is she gonna do with
her housecoat so ya know it's bad but
we'll see we'll see on round two but I
like it over there I prefer it cost a
living we bought a bar
get lucky everybody we on the get lucky
bar and restaurant and travels cheap
over there so visit come because
breakfast over breaks you can just
travel like to Perry whenever you wants
to within Europe yeah yeah yeah I mean
you don't need about you here right
because your peers need a right the path
work no no no no Schengen there's like
Schengen territory it's a European Union
there's only a few places like now with
the UK you need it yeah because they're
pulling out now you will need it yeah
but before that was a whole that was the
whole idea behind that you ride a
bicycle like the United States I would
love children Europe you might have I've
done weird shows in Croatia and Slovenia
I just did some like especially former
Yugoslavia they speak like 17 languages
because just everybody speaks multiple
languages were the only morons the only
ones
it's a mate and my husband speaks
foreign language is I didn't know he was
fluent in Spanish like it was a surprise
we went to Barcelona you started having
a conversation with a cab driver that's
another one I don't understand I just do
a lot of smiling and nodding like a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
I don't retain anything just information
just [ __ ] bounces right off me wow so
you have our special no it's all yeah on
Netflix they're ready they ready six of
us six ladies so so it's Tiffani I
haven't watched any of them yeah I have
to admit does she introduce but it's
separate it's broken up into separate
cycle yeah six separate episodes that's
cool June autumn the Divas are what
you're gonna show us Showtime - um I did
a few I did
a couple Toria right yeah yeah yeah
Tiffany was in that one you did a half
hour cometh central I know I never did a
half hour Comedy Central I did host the
AVN Awards how's that you know it wasn't
bad it was actually kind of fun to write
for I do stuff for that of course I
guess to women and their big claim to
fame that my co-host had award-winning
[ __ ] like my never even won an
honorable mention what was weird was
they gave you all the screeners and
there were like a hundred and some
categories so they gave me this duffel
bag filled with porn stable amount of
porn in my house if anybody ever broke
in you say because I'm though it was an
improv oh no I know I do hyenas well
that's that's a guy for now Addison the
manager there he was did mama Kiki and I
remember they found a big old box of
porn at the Edison himself maybe I wish
it was me who left it I just gave it to
my neighbor who's kind of creeping every
once in a while I give him like a
Christmas box of corn
even four years five every year some I'm
not gonna watch that's not that's not
gaping [ __ ] it's not gonna be my
genre these people when they got these
awards we had cake quickly right so
excited but if they don't win they leave
so by the end of the night the audience
is empty I don't think I was invited to
it I know I did go to some like thing at
a club and then my brother was there
he's like 21 I'm just so excited entire
life I don't win the DPO word of mouth
yeah Awards - they're so nice that you
feel like there is an element of sadness
but I don't think they're in on it yet
it's that like movie that life after
porn or after yeah their prefrontal
cortex forms they're like finally have
the realization that they [ __ ] up
their lives a little bit yeah children
yeah that life after porn is sad
Jeremy's sad to talk about now he's just
stated around too long I think as far as
you look back on his career I don't
think there's a sadness that guys think
about but for women he's still too long
yeah you don't say all the society had
to do that he had to do that Friz living
sad when they have to like go to some
town where nobody knows and yeah I think
it's that if you have a kid yeah and
that kid can just their friends can
Google oh my god they're sure mommy
it'll be over I mean there could just
stumble upon you while they're searching
for their own stuff just like you below
you the real names you don't have to I'm
sorry it's your mom that she did
something years ago you Google you're 15
and you're Google and porn and you run
across a video carmella Bing was like
there's been a couple teachers fired
because of girls gone wild whatever
happened to that yeah shows coming up I
do I'm at rooster T feathers and
Sunnyvale this weekend I'm in Iowa of
penguins next weekend and then I come
back and I think I forget what I'm I'm
somewhere else yeah I got a cookie
further Bob bender went there once bro
it's nice I don't know what I cook
whatever the weather sunny walked out
but I was right now they put me up like
red cross the street it's and it was an
it used to be a much nicer hotel it's
always sad okay somehow lose a contract
for a great comic myth it up yeah it is
it's always like one animal you're like
I got got one time smoking weed out of
the window in Detroit this was Detroit
taking my head out the window smoking a
joint and they called what happened
nothing they just they Club called me I
was like hey can you put your head back
in the window and put that joint out
somebody just saw are you I really
thought I was like at least respectful
enough to stick my hand
oh we had when we were in Orlando you
rolled up a joint in the broom and we
didn't smoke it there but we got a they
were replacing the TVs in all the rooms
remember and one of the workers ratted
him out to the hotel and said that there
was a weed smell so then I got a call
from the club
saying that there was a strong weed
smell in the room when they came in
earlier today and I was like we didn't
smoke I said oh well he was rolling up a
joint but we didn't smoke it in here and
she's like oh okay I figured he wouldn't
he was smarter than that and I'm like
why is everybody on you oh it's a TV guy
rat on me you don't even work for the
hotel right supposed to be minding your
own business anyway [ __ ] put that [ __ ]
in where do you go though I'm always
standing on the hotel toilets like
sticking my head in a vent I always go
outside got a creeper you know in the
darkness a woman element of like rape
murder combo that's right when you were
telling Martin like how to find a cheap
apartment and all that stuff I didn't
say anything last night but he's gotta
what he has to think of her she can't
live just everywhere the where Martin
you know it's heart you can't you know
she can't even walk from the garage to
her car to the house or whatever that's
you know you got to think about those
things yes my I feel like men don't walk
the road you never realize like it's a
way harder I put in no Alec outdoor
access I'm like they're gonna murder me
they at least have to come through a
lobby you gotta try a little hard
everyone like these um edge over man
Elayne Boosler like what time I was in
my dating was three guys who was don't
worry about [ __ ] guys oh great
they'll kill you and I take turns off
would you calm the [ __ ] down
Oh scary I'm gonna badge go walk around
your block no you can't go night-night
valium we got treadmill treadmill for
the house and stuff because I can't I
just like I don't feel safe because cars
will stop they'll slow down when you're
walking this is my neighborhood for man
jerking off in public to an open mind
and the cat a corner like worry is
dispelled good you off he cut like so
say I was crossing the street going to
the drive his car cut me off cat a
corner so I had no choice but to either
go back or like I couldn't go around or
in front of him and then he raised his
pelvis to show sweet jerk scared scared
jerk jerks let me pull that and pull
that out in the bedroom bro the scared
jerks [ __ ] kid in Atlanta who sent me
dick pics he was an open mic ER and then
I sent them to I sent his dick pics to
every comedy club down there and I was
like Marcy the punchline doesn't want to
see his dad now she does not and then I
told him I informed him that he wouldn't
be working so I was just smart enough to
send it and you were dumb enough to say
yeah Wow
[Laughter]
that is gross yeah that's gross it's
like after after the weekend with you
madam oh no I never it was just like a
real you didn't work with you that so
random dick in my inbox
just kidding can open for you no woman's
ever been real jazzed up about a dick in
our inbox to a guy randomly hey no never
never never never it's not even that
exciting if it's your like my dude say
yeah but yeah right I think you make
clear you I bet you got this wrist
motion here got him off that's what he
was hoping it was behind an old folks
home and I was Easter and I was carrying
high this the pie one was pretty young
yeah no I was probably 20 and I was
scared you're scared I mean yeah it's
riddled with perverts out there died but
the old folks home like he's he just
jerking off to old people
I dropped my rhubarb pie and I ran that
guy was just standing looking in the old
folks home window that was across the
street wrinkles out and then he got
caught
pretzel and you got a free prize Oh
Manny it's confusing
why'd you guys think though but what did
they think a girl is gonna do you're
shutting the door a meeting I think some
guys named if I show him a picture of
their dick you know like it what up
where do you live never I don't know I
don't know one woman who's never never
never never never no you don't know the
girl like like you're not gonna
conversation look like that a lot of
things didn't like your bro
even though the conversations we don't
need that if you're not intimate with
that person oh no what you're saying is
even if you are into another person
you're not even bothering to have a
question like who my ex used to do that
and they were hilarious like it'd be
like it's dick in a wine glass but like
a cheese wheel next to it [ __ ] gerber
daisies okay maybe you could bake you a
cake I feel like most men better in a
suit oh yeah we're not looking - it'd be
a [ __ ] pocket square and I'll be
excited I think you're a real sassy
gentleman
you're [ __ ] dead hog what about the
balls make you mine stay in the [ __ ]
balls look like homemade cheese this
will be a st. Paul Minnesota first time
in st. Paul Minnesota this Friday
October labor at the old way Center San
Antonio Texas October 26 tobin Center
second show at it just at it show at it
San Diego November 2nd humphreys by the
bay West Jordan Utah Salt Lake City Utah
back Jordan landing ok Jordan land in
Utah November 8 and November 9 wise guys
also soon to be I'm coming soon to
Modesto
Bakersfield Napa Valley Seattle Spokane
Pittsburgh
shut up to Easton you see me off sunset
with this butter pocket car angry
October 16th the par Mountain LA and
evil as jokes November 11 oh we do have
a Spanish show next Tuesday it's better
shows Monday yeah and some money at San
Diego a golden palace golden palace and
then Tuesday cutter Torres in Sylmar
what's up fool that's
no more right no more whatever you want
hold that last comment static love The
Last Comic Standing the one on the moat
I was when you guys were sequestered
then yeah we're not sequestered at all
you were free to go we were on the Queen
Mary so living there like yeah yeah I
mean I ain't lived there for long right
yeah I don't know I I mean my stay was
not know it was not an extended stay I
was there I mean I got kicked off second
but I don't even doing comedy like three
and a half years but yeah but I didn't
have very much material he was running I
was it was running low agent who got you
on got you an audition or did you do the
cattle call no I had a friend who got me
on because I had done Montreal the year
before I was a new face the year before
and then that old 505 - I don't know
what to do I was I was nervous I mean if
the first show went well the second show
I think i weeped in my hotel room after
it I did some like soft rock she's right
they give it a one show and then we and
everybody was like all right
it was all right and they were like the
first year that give us a trial show
first before the showcase yeah to get
ready for the showcase and but I feel
like I had one good industry show and
then one real stinker real stinker
Doodle and then I was so sad like I
didn't know how to process my emotions I
have my show was great because I'm not I
know that we were like gonna write up I
think that was a main showcase one but
then ever another show where nobody gave
a [ __ ] about nobody came to the second
yeah no wack well there yeah my second
one I didn't do well you could tell like
who
the crowd was jumping on everybody was
jumping on the flight of a there was
there that year that was their breakout
year I feel like Dan Cummins was yes
Jasper and Natasha jo koy jo koy yes and
I had only been doing comedy like two
years at that point you guys were on
fresh faces or new new faces and then
you did premium blend same here too
right no I never he did Comedy Central
on the Dave Attell thing at Al gave me
so I've only done like the filthy yours
was through Gabriel pretty much right
when he did his when he did his you got
the premium Lynne around the scene no no
that's a preowned blend at 2005 okay but
you get to go to Amsterdam through that
show no sounds of fun though there was a
guy as much we all who was booking a
talk show and Rotterdam oh really
it's called ramadas lot no they're all
in Dutch he booked me and Natasha had
some other people and man of my first
time in Europe I didn't know how to take
meetings after that like nobody like I
feel like you're so nobody I'm a manager
the time I did and then I remember I had
some meetings at like UTA and they were
like what do you want out of your career
and I was like I just want to be great
no I hear it was a horrible and I don't
know what to do well I assign me there
was about two editions and I do you send
a guy out there who never acted you let
me know how to read a script or
highlight anything so I was read for
like good movies that now if I read them
now what I got him yeah I read for
natural lever there I could have been
one of the priests do anything yeah I
was just an idiot don't know how to come
people back yeah no no no and yeah yeah
the UM the general meeting is what
people don't know how to do and we were
clueless and he was getting sent out
right after he one last comment he got
sent out for like three general meetings
and if you don't know what to do it just
becomes you sitting there with a free
bottle of water like staring at each
other and uh I was when I met that woman
on CB
as the first right we just sat there so
right and you don't know what to say oh
they're just like in an interview almost
like a job in expect Odom when on that
scene I'm at dinner playing chart
Bukowski he brings them into the office
so you're a writer huh Henry yeah this
is Gemma my neighbor he's a writer too I
thought maybe I'll get you guys together
so they just smoke you for one of my
stain [ __ ] can I be excused
yes yeah yeah cuz you got to sell
yourself you got to go and now that you
know I know what to not to do I just
picture myself at Jim Carrey in Dumb and
Dumber when he got that cookout every
party and he has a sweater he's over
excited to be there I just don't get be
half of that you have to like razzle and
dazzle they just nobody told me that not
only people are gonna tell you that they
saw you're special but they didn't
really see it so you got to be okay with
that no I love you were gonna laugh and
you gotta laugh with their when they
laugh oh yeah and no and they were
sending you out blindly and then I said
went through the next stage and I was
like look we need some help these
general meetings I need to know why he
needs to say we need to work on that
here so he could be ready when it goes
out there cuz he's looking like a wobbly
dog they're looking for somebody they
can start to they can go mold a guy
let's put him with a writer let's put
him with let's maybe have him a guest
star on this show whatever you know that
their wheels are supposed to be spinning
while you're talking to them there look
they're watching you to see if you can
do something on TV it really is a
horrible business like emotionally like
there's a lot of crying like people are
pitching right now and
let the main lady or the main person for
every CA seen every every 25 minutes he
has to hit and watch it listen to
another pitch median oh so we're talking
100 pitches per week oh yeah whatever
you have found you quietly would it be
yours
that's not when every half hours so much
so that they're juggling everybody
else's schedules like we can't do this
anymore can you do 1015 1015 how long we
have now you know it's like getting cut
into quarter hours do you mean a
Greenblatt's oh yes so food Johnny Roku
right here was crooked what's up dog oh
yeah man just you find me on Instagram
lately
oh okay Johnny yeah climbing a mountain
a big monster oh yeah I'm rock climbing
lifted I lifted my hand to a point where
like I rubbed it off so when I swung off
a rock I like I had to hold my hand with
another hand with my other hand oh no
like I was trying to move from one rock
to another and I and I lost gripping and
that ripped like my hand that piece off
my skin yeah then I cleaned it with
alcohol like a [ __ ] idiot that shirt
yeah so you see I've done it apart
give me switching hands so what happened
to fall off what do you land into oh you
just laying down like the soft matting
but you just gotta like make sure you
don't land awkwardly like have pretty
angora burning my hair I'm gonna try not
to get on my rocker like attached to
like a rope or something not for a rock
wall bouldering but like yeah we're not
going like straight up high where'd you
go science center none I love that for
kids
[Laughter]
[Music]
the club 82 or it was over in Arcadia
like you put you pay to climb along well
yeah my friend has a gym membership so
hey come with me it's Mike feet it
smells like people that use those
crystals for do what they're supposed to
but I'm sure a lot of dudes like cutoff
jean shorts
[Laughter]
what stuff we'll take you April Macie
thank you so much thanks we love
watching your photo of the world I want
to go there get lucky yeah get lucky
what's up we're gonna get lucky if you
ever want to go I want you a plan I'll
plan your trip yeah we should try and do
a little European tour well it's really
gonna happen after Netflix what's up
fool